[Music]
to the delight of many fans many new
details about the upcoming the
expandables 4 were announced at
cinemacon the movie will officially be
called the expendables with a 4 instead
of an a in the title and will be much
more violent than its predecessor
moreover we now know who exactly will be
involved in the blockbuster the
published cast list includes names like
jason statham dolph lunker and curtis
jackson aka 50 cent megan foxx andy
garcia and of course sylvester stallone
the plot is expected to focus on a
potential nuclear war between the united
states and russia which makes the topic
as relevant as ever we also learned from
a statement by stallone that this will
be the last expandables movie starring
him instead there will be more emphasis
on characters like statham's league
christmas in the future in addition to
the expandables which is scheduled to
hit theaters in the course of next year
a spin-off of jason statham's character
is also being planned along with a
female counterpart called the
expendables
fast and furious fans were in for a
surprise when director justin lin
announced his exit from fast and furious
10. allegedly there were various
conflicts between lin and the studio for
example he is said to have been faced
with a screenwriter with whom he did not
get along well then diesel who is a
producer besides his work as an actor is
also believed to have contributed
significantly to lin's departure on
april 23rd there's said to have been a
big dispute then diesel seems not to
have backed down on certain demands
regarding the film which was probably
too much for the director both sides
came to an agreement and decided to look
for a new director which is an extremely
costly affair each missed day of
shooting is set to cost the studio up to
1 million us dollars in expenses besides
it was necessary to find not only any
director but one who's willing to lower
his own creative standards after all the
requirements of diesel and universal
have to be met with frenchman louis
literally they may have found that
person in any case he has already
produced some good movies like the
transporter or now you see me we are
eager to find out how the production
will evolve under the new direction fast
and furious 10 is scheduled for release
on may 19 2023
there's news from the marvel cinematic
universe as disney revealed recently
there are changes in the release dates
of the marvels and ant-man and the wasp
quantum mania the marvels is pushed back
a few months and will no longer be
released in february but on july 28 2023
in exchange the new ant-man film will
take over the old release date of the
marvels and will now hit theaters
significantly earlier on february 17
2023 according to disney's official
announcement this has a very convenient
reasons as ant-man 3 is presently in a
much more advanced stage of production
than planned further information is
available on another mcu film namely
fantastic four the release date has not
been altered here but there has been a
change of director as deadline reporter
john watts has left the project because
he needs some distance from the
superhero genre for the time being this
is more than comprehensible after all
the 40 year old directed the entire
spiderman trilogy with tom holland his
former employer also shows sympathy in a
statement marvel boss kevin feige
expressly wishes to work with him again
in the future now watts is responsible
for a thriller on apple tv plus that
features a top class cast including
george clooney and brad pitt and that
fits perfectly with the desired
superhero break unfortunately it is not
yet known when exactly and above all
with which director fantastic four will
go into production
fans have been waiting for the next
installment of the mission impossible
franchise to be released since january
2019. now after many eventless months
during the pandemic new details are
finally coming to light the movie
previously known only as mission
impossible 7 now has a new title mission
impossible death reckoning part 1. hence
the upcoming eighth part will be mission
impossible dead reckoning part two a
first trailer was shown to selected
people at the recent cinemacon but it
has not yet been published online
according to eyewitness reports the
trailer shows a conversation between
ethan hunt and his ex-boss eugene
kitteridge who was last seen in the very
first mission impossible film there are
also exciting shots from the well-known
filming locations of venice the vatican
and the vast desert in addition to tom
cruise as ethan hunt and henry cherny as
kittridge the trailer also features
vanessa kirby as white widow and rebecca
ferguson as ilsa at the end of the
trailer tom cruise daring motorcycle
stunt over a cliff and norway can be
admired though there were no big
surprises the shown material looks very
promising for a traditional mission
impossible movie
many fans are looking forward to the
next installments of the john wick
franchise including the series the
continental and the spin-off ballerina
this news about the latter is shooting
is set to start already this summer the
plot of the spin-off revolves around a
young follower of the ballerinas this is
a group of female assassins who are
trained by the director incidentally
this is something they have in common
with john wick since he too was made
into the killer he is today by ruska
roma when he was an orphan like the
young john wick the young assassin
rooney brown also has the ambitious goal
of becoming a professional killer having
had her entire family murdered she now
seeks revenge she suspects elias mueller
the mayor of the unremarkable town of
sunnyvale to be behind the crime after
the filming with leading actress hannah
de armas failed to start as planned in
2020 due to the pandemic the shooting is
now scheduled to begin this summer
lion's gate should have enough to do at
the moment anyway since john wick
chapter 4 is currently in
post-production it looks like fans can
also expect an appearance by keanu
reeves as john wick in ballerina we
would be very surprised if lionsgate
missed the opportunity the director is
len weissman who was already in charge
of john wick chapter 3 parabellum
there's no release date for ballerina
yet but the next movie from the
franchise will be john wick chapter 4
anyways due for release on march 24th
2023
john krasinski's a quiet place was a
huge success among horror and thriller
fans in its 2018 release year the story
is explained quite simply earth has been
conquered by mysterious aliens who are
drawn to sounds thanks to their
sensitive hearing those who have not yet
fallen victim to the so-called death
angels must lead their lives in absolute
silence otherwise they will be slain by
the monsters a quiet place and its
sequels are about the abbott family
played by the actors emily blunt john
krasinski millicent simmons and noah
jupe after a quiet place 2 was already
released in theaters last summer rumors
about a third part started to pile up
krazynski did confirm that the story of
the abbots is not over yet but that we
will have to wait until at least 2025.
however a spinoff announced that
cinemacon is expected to be released
much sooner on the september 22nd 2023
the official title of the movie is a
quiet place day one which already gives
us a rough idea of the plot the spin-off
will certainly deal with the original
arrival of the aliens as its main
subject fittingly the movie is likely to
be much more chaotic than the main
series after all when the aliens arrived
the humans had no idea how to survive
the battle against them the extremely
costly learning process could then also
take place in a different setting for
example in a big city with many
potential victims behind the scenes
director michael sanofsky is to helm the
movie after jeff nichols left the
production to pursue a sci-fi project of
his own zarnovsky is still largely
unknown but has already had some success
with his film pig starring nicholas cage
we are definitely excited to see what
the young director will come up with in
a quiet place day one and are looking
forward to the movie which will hit
theaters on september 22nd 2023
that's it for our news today this week
we suggest you watch the new trailer for
the obi-wan kenobi series as well as the
new trailer for the game of thrones
prequel house of the dragon you don't
want to miss it
[Music]